is the AWS Cloud practitioner
certification actually worth it now if
you're someone on a journey of learning
AWS you probably come across the cloud
practitioner certification time and time
again many people say it's a great
starting point and that you need to pass
a certification before doing anything
else but is the certification exam right
for everyone well for me the answer was
yes I started my Cloud Learning Journey
by studying for the AWS Cloud
practitioner exam it helps me understand
the basics of the cloud the AWS core
services and the best practices when it
came to pricing security and
architecting but after getting five AWS
certifications and working two years at
AWS as a Solutions architect my
perspective has definitely changed I
realized that the true value on the
certification wasn't in passing the exam
or getting a certified badge but rather
the foundational knowledge it provides
and the pathways opens up for further
learning let's break this down a bit so
the AWS Cloud practitioner certification
is an entry-level certification it
examines the basics of AWS cloud and
here are some of the topics that AWS
certificate education covers the exam is
90 minutes long and has 65 multiple
choice or more to response questions now
is it enough to land you a job probably
not but if you're a beginner to the
cloud the certification will provide you
with a structured learning path to learn
the fundamentals and so in order to
determine whether this certification is
right for you here are the three factors
to consider the first one is your career
goals and objectives does this
certification align with your long-term
career goals the second factor is market
demand and Trends is the certification
in demand in the world of cloud and
artificial intelligence and the third
factor is cost and time investment how
much does this certification cost and is
it worth the time investment let's start
off with the first factor which is
career goals and objectives if your goal
is to become a Solutions architect a
cloud engineer or any other technical
role that requires understanding of AWS
then yes the cloud practitioner
certification is a great starting point
but just remember that the certification
will only provide you with the
foundational understanding of AWS
services in order to maximize your
chances of Landing a cloud job you need
to gain some hands-on experience and one
great way to gain this experience is by
building Cloud projects this
certification can also be quite useful
for students and people working in
non-technical roles for students you can
use this certification to figure out
whether you want to pursue a career in
the cloud and for those in non-technical
roles like project management or sales
the certification can help you
communicate better with technical teams
in your company for example when I
worked at AWS it was recommended for
everyone in the cloud sales team to get
the cloud practitioner certification
this was to help them have better
discussions with the AWS customers and
also the solutions architects in the
company okay another factor is market
demand and Trends because if you're
learning something you want to make sure
it's useful and relevant for the future
right well with all the changes that
have been happening recently with AI
it's really hard to predict what the
future holds but what I can say for sure
is that right now AWS skills are still
in demand AWS is the leading cloud
provider with about 32 market share and
as more companies start to use cloud
computing the demand for professionals
with AWS expertise will continue to grow
in fact as of this year more than 90
percent of Fortune 100 companies use AWS
services so if you're looking to learn
the cloud AWS is definitely the one I
recommend going for keep in mind that
this market demand is not just for
technical roles even in non-technical
roles having a basic understanding of
the cloud can be quite valuable it can
help you understand the larger I.T
strategy of your company and help you
make more informed decisions and who
knows maybe in 10 to 15 years Cloud
engineers and solutions Architects will
be replaced by AI but I do believe that
humans will still be required in the
tech industry to work alongside Ai and
so cloud is still a good first step into
a career in Tech the third factor I
would consider is time and cost
investment the exam fee for the AWS
Cloud practitioner certification is
around 100 USD and compared to the other
AWS certifications this fee is
relatively low if you want to be
strategic about it and save some money
you could go straight to a difficult
certification for example the solutions
acting associate that way instead of
paying 250 for both exams you would only
be paying a hundred and fifty dollars
however if you're a complete beginner to
the cloud I wouldn't recommend doing
that since preparing for a harder exam
straight away might discourage you from
studying for the certification but if
you feel comfortable with skipping a few
steps you could definitely go straight
to the associate level certifications in
terms of time investment the cloud
practice should a certification took me
about three weeks or 16 hours of study
this again is quite low compared to the
other certifications because just for
comparison the solutions Arctic
professional took me about 100 hours of
studying so for the 16 hours of study
here's how my time was broken down I
spent the first hour setting up an AWS
account and trying out the different
Services then I spent 11 hours going
through video lectures over Cloud
practitioner course on udemy and finally
before my exam I spent another four
hours doing practice exams now this
certification might be intimidating at
the start especially if you're new to
AWS but the good news is there are so
many resources out there to help you get
started if you're interested in getting
the AWS Cloud practitioner certification
I would highly recommend checking out
the AWS Cloud courses on udemy udemy is
an online learning platform with over
200 000 courses and 57 million students
I personally use this udemy course
taught by Stefan mark and it told me
everything I needed to know to pass the
exam Stefan has a really unique teaching
style he's able to break down technical
topics into a way that's concise and
easy to understand for the practice
questions I recommend this set of cloud
practitioner exams created by tutorials
Dojo there are five practice exams in
this course with 340 questions
altogether which is more than enough to
help you get familiar with these types
of questions that will come up in the
actual exam another great resource from
udemy is this learn AWS in a weekend
course which is exactly what the title
says a course for you to learn AWS in
just a weekend this is great if you're
not too sure whether you want to commit
to learning AWS and it gives you a great
taste into the world of cloud computing
but yeah udemy has become one of the
go-to places for learning AWS Cloud so
if you're interested in checking out
their courses I'll put links in the
description below to a list of my top
recommended AWS Cloud courses they offer
huge discounts from time to time so make
sure you take a look at the links below
to see if there's a course that might be
useful for you alright so after taking
those three factors into consideration
career goals market trends a timer cost
investment here are the pros and cons of
getting the AWS practitioner exam the
biggest advantage of taking this
certification is that it serves as a
foundation for future learning it
provides a really solid base for you to
pursue more certifications and gives you
that stepping stone to gain more
specialized knowledge later on another
Pro is market demand given that AWS has
a significant market share there's a
strong demand for it professionals to
understand Cloud more specifically AWS
Cloud it also increases your
employability when you add the
certification onto your resume and
finally the certification is relatively
low in cost and time investment compared
to the other certifications this makes
it more accessible for those of you who
are just starting out in your Cloud
journey and exploring the field of AWS
plus there's so many resources out there
for you to prepare for the exam however
there's a also a few cons or drawbacks
that come with this certification the
AWS Cloud practitioner certification by
itself does not provide enough technical
depth it only covers the AWS services at
a very basic level and won't provide you
with the technical detail you need for
the more technical roles but honestly
this certification isn't designed to do
that it's not designed to make you an
AWS expert the exam covers a broad range
of cloud topics and gives you a glimpse
of what you can expect if you want to go
deeper into AWS Cloud so I'd recommend
taking this into consideration and try
to dive deeper either by getting more
AWS certifications or building real
world projects another drawback is that
this certification doesn't help you
stand out as much compared to if you
were to do a higher level certification
for example if you have the solutions
Arctic associate certification or the
developer associate certification
instead and so getting the certification
by itself usually would not be enough
but just remember that every expert was
once a beginner and this certification
is a great starting point for beginners
so overall I believe the AWS Cloud
practitioner certification is worth it
in many types of situations but it also
just depends on what your career and
learning goals are my personal opinion
is that everyone in it should consider
getting this certification because at
the speed in which cloud is growing
having a foundational level
certification will definitely come in
handy to get started don't forget to
check out the courses Below on udemy and
let me know your thoughts on this
certification in the comments below do
you think it's worth it and would you
recommend it to others alright bye for
now